the former president's campaign says he
is already making money off of this
around 8 million dollars in
contributions joining us now to discuss
all of this our CBS News chief White
House correspondent Nancy Cordes and CBS
News legal analyst Ricky cleeman good
morning to both of you Ricky I want to
ask you we've been hearing about this
indictment but today we will actually
see it it will be in our hot little
hands when you get it what will you look
for inside of it to say okay this is a
strong case this is a weak case to give
you a sense of what the actual case is
well just like at Christmas when you
really want to open the big present
first what I will look at is what are
each charge so I want to go to the
bottom of each charge and find out what
they are then I'm going to go back and I
assume it's a speaking indictment which
means that it is written as a narrative
and in that case we're going to know
exactly what the facts are that support
the charge if it's not a speaking
indictment well then we still have a
little guesswork because it'll be more
complicated and Technical correct let me
ask you about the judge Ricky president
Trump has already been trying to soften
up the rafts saying this judge hates him
what do we know about the judge and is
it possible that they could move to have
another judge moved in and is that part
of the theater or is this actually a
smart legal strategy well he may really
feel that the judge quote unquote hates
him because the judge was the one who
presided over the trial of Alan
weisselberg in the Trump organization
his rulings I would say were firm but
fair I'm sure that Donald Trump would
say his rulings were not fair but the
one thing he did say at the time of
sentencing weisselberg was that he
wished he could give him a tougher
sentence so it does give the defense
team some room to argue but his
reputation is Stellar he's been on the
bench for 16 years people say he keeps
good order in the courtroom and so
that's what we want someone who knows
Rules of Evidence and procedure Joe
tacopino was smart as Trump's attorney
he said on air I have no idea how I feel
about him I've never appeared before and
let me watch him they did add another
attorney to the case though Todd Blanche
what can you tell us about him Todd
Blanche is a white-collar lawyer he is
someone who was a former assistant U.S
attorney in New York he was with a major
what we call Silk Stocking law firm
called Cadwallader one of the most
prestigious in the country he resigned
because he said that this was an
opportunity he could not pass up he's
formidable I think that it will change
the tenor of what we have seen recently
about this case Nancy as John mentioned
the Trump campaign they're reporting
that they're getting these donations for
this indictment to the tune of around 8
million dollars what do you make of this
and is this money accessible to him get
yourself indicted and raise a lot of
money that's how his lawyer Joe takapina
put it yesterday we saw the former
president fundraising from his motorcade
as he was heading from the airport
yesterday to Trump Tower the the big
question is are these donations coming
from new supporters who want to help him
out or are these people who would have
given him money at some point in the
campaign anyway they're just rallying to
his defense right now I think it's too
early to say whether all of this
attention is going to help him or hurt
him in the fundraising game in the long
run it all depends on so many factors is
there a trial what happens in that trial
does he get charged with other crimes
down the road there's so many unknowns
right now
what are you hearing though behind the
scenes from Republicans and some of
those who may be even potentially
running against him well it's a really
tough needle to thread if you are a
republican who wants to run against him
who wants to eventually siphon off some
of his sizable base I'm thinking of a
Mike Pence or a Nikki Haley you really
can't go right at him and criticize him
because then you risk alienating those
supporters so you've got to kind of go
this third route where you don't support
him but maybe you attack the legal
system or the D.A and say that it's you
know it's it's unfair a little political
posturing exactly but if you are a
republican like Chris Christie or ASA
Hutchinson who wants to sort of position
yourself as the anti-trump if you will
then you've got a little more room and
they have taken that room to say look
this is a guy who's already in legal
trouble he may be in a lot more legal
trouble over the next year and a half is
this really who we want they talk about
lanes and politics how big is that lane
is it a big four lane highway or is it
tiny little bike lane the anti-trump
lane among the presidential the
anti-trump lane if you look at the polls
is at most half the party and and even
then you know it It's Tricky and so you
know you've seen people like Ron
DeSantis the governor of Florida kind of
tiptoe into that lane and then go oh
actually this is a narrow Lane I don't
think I want to be in this Lane yeah and
then and then Retreat and I think that
that is going to be a challenge that you
see Republicans facing over and over
again in this race now Ricky we know
that this could go according to plan
today or it could turn out to be a
circus but what are you looking forward
to the next few days well I think that
today really will go according to plan
you have a good judge you have lawyers
who are not going to aggravate that
judge he will get processed at the
courthouse quietly there may or may not
be a mug shot I hear there will not be a
mug shot we all know who he is but it's
also possible using Nancy's points that
they may want to raise funds off of that
mug shot and that would be unseemly mug
shots are not usually public in New York
what I do think over the next couple of
days that we're going to see we're going
to have a press conference by Alvin
Bragg later this afternoon we'll get a
much Fuller picture from the prosecution
Donald Trump is going to Mar-A-Lago he
will have his press conference tonight
from there all things shall flow yes
well Ricky I know you're going to be
with us later for our specials coverage
thank you so much and Nancy Cordes thank
you as always